Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bevor es losgeht mit diesem Kurzpass ein kleiner Hinweis. Wir haben leider auf der Spur des Gastes Peter Ahrens ein leichtes Knacken. Das ging nicht mehr rauszubekommen und hat sicherlich auch damit zu tun, dass es eben nicht ganz so einfach ist, eine Verbindung zwischen Moskau und München herzustellen mit einem Equipment, was eben dann auch in einen Reisekoffer passen muss. Nichtsdestotrotz finde ich die Folge sehr höhrenswert und hoffe euch geht es auch so. Es sollte auch definitiv höhrenswert sein, auch von der Qualität her. Bitte vergeb die kleinen Knackser, ließ sich leider nicht anders hinbekommen. Jetzt viel Spaß mit dem Kurzpass. Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wie ist es eigentlich, vor Ort bei einer Weltmeisterschaft in Russland Journalist zu sein? Diese Frage und noch viele andere stellen wir jetzt Peter Ahrens vom Spiegel hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Peter, ich grüße dich.
Hallo Max.
Sehr schön, dass das mal wieder geklappt hat. Du bist die ganze Zeit in Russland vor Ort, um über die WM zu berichten. Warum bist du jetzt überhaupt noch da, wo doch die Deutschen ausgeschieden sind? Gibt es jetzt noch was zu berichten?
Weil ich kein Spieler bin, sondern Journalist. Wäre vielleicht die eine Antwort. Und es gibt ja noch eine ganze Menge zu berichten. Es sind ja noch ein, zwei Mannschaften im Wettbewerb. Aber tatsächlich habe ich von einem Kollegen gehört, der darf ab jetzt nichts mehr schreiben, weil es geließen hat, dass er...
Aber er ist noch weiter vor Ort?
Er ist jetzt quasi urlaubend, so mehr oder weniger. Es wurde ihm gesagt, die WM sei vorbei, und deswegen würde man nicht mehr Berichtenswertes finden. Obwohl das Achtelfinale erst losgeht, obwohl außer Deutschland alle Favoriten noch im Wettbewerb sind, obwohl es eine Weltmeisterschaft ist, die nur alle vier Jahre stattfindet. Aber so sehen das offenbar auch deutsche Medien.
Ja, verrückt. Aber dass man dann sogar den Reporter noch vor Ort behält und ihn nicht wieder zurückholt nach Deutschland. Na gut, aber dann macht man eben Urlaub in Russland. Und wie ist das so als Journalist in Russland? Wie oft musstest du dich schon gegen die Staatsmacht stellen, Peter?
Also die Staatsmacht tritt ja in dem Fall eher auf im Sinne von irgendwelchen Sicherheits-Security-Leuten, die einem irgendwelche Zugänge im Stadion gerade verweigern bzw. sagen, man dürfe nicht durch diese Tür, man müsse durch die andere Tür. Aber das ist, glaube ich, nicht russisch spezifisch, wenn man das so nennen kann. Sondern das hat man eigentlich bei allen großen Turnieren ja diesen Security-Hype und ehrlich gesagt finde ich den sogar hier in Russland sogar ein Stück unauffälliger als z.B. in Frankreich vor zwei Jahren. Offenbar machen die das hier einfach geschickter.
Ja, stimmt. Das war aber ja auch ein großes Thema, weil er eben 2016 natürlich zusammenhängend mit den Anschlägen, die es damals ja gab, u.a. auch im Fußballumfeld beim Freundschaftsspiel Deutschland gegen Frankreich. Da haben wir damals viel drüber gesprochen, wieso die Einlasskontrollen waren, was man alles mitnehmen durfte in Stadion und was nicht. Ich habe mich u.a. mit Matthias Fribe neulich mal im Kurzpass unterhalten. Der hat mir erzählt, er ist verpflichtet von seinem Arbeitgeber her, sein ganzes technisches Equipment immer am Mann zu haben, selbst wenn er gerade keine Live-Schalte nach Deutschland plant. Und da haben wir uns auch kurz darüber ausgetauscht, wie das wohl in Frankreich so funktioniert hätte, mit so viel elektronischen Dingen, mit ganz vielen Kabeln herumzulaufen. Aber das ist ein bisschen entspannter in Russland.
Technisches Equipment habe ich ja auch nicht so viel. Also bis auf meinen Laptop. Wenn man Kugelschreiber als technisches Equipment bezeichnet, dann hätte ich es dann noch mehr. Aber da sind die Audiokollegen ja sicherlich noch mit mehr Problemen behaftet. Also das geht noch.
Das ist schön. Und wie muss man sich jetzt deinen Arbeitsalltag vor Ort vorstellen? Was hast du dir jetzt so die letzten Tage getrieben und was wartet jetzt noch auf dich?
Naja, der Arbeitsalter der letzten Tage war natürlich geprägt durch das Südkoreaspiel, durch das Ausscheiden. Da hatte man natürlich dann ein bisschen mehr zu tun, als man das vielleicht 90 Minuten vorher so sich überlegt hatte. Wir hatten tatsächlich schon so einen Nachhalt bei diesem Schwedenspieler, also im zweiten Spiel schon natürlich aus der Redaktion so ein, ich sag mal Notfallplan entwickelt für The Day After, den musste man dann quasi nur vier Tage weiter datieren. Insofern war das noch ganz machbar und das hat dann nicht alle völlig in Panik gestürzt, auch in der Heimatredaktion in Hamburg.
Aber was heißt das dann? Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Texte schon formuliert waren und ihr musstet nur ein neues Datum drüber?
Nein, das nicht. Aber es ist zum Beispiel, es wird halt vorher festgelegt, so wie viele Nachdrehungen zum Beispiel für jedes Spiel angedacht sind. Und ein normales Deutschlandspiel außerhalb der WM hat so zwei, höchstens, manchmal auch gerne einen, also gerade bei Länderspielen der letzten Zeit kam man eigentlich mit einem Nachdreh immer prima aus. Und bei einer WM natürlich, wo das Interesse deutlich höher ist und logischerweise auch höher ist, sind es so mal so drei und in diesem Fall waren es natürlich, ja ich glaube, wir haben acht Texte gemacht insgesamt, mein Kollege Markus Krämer und ich zu diesem Spiel, weil das natürlich dann immer ganz noch mehr impliziert und muss natürlich nicht nur das Spiel beschreiben, sondern muss eigentlich gar nicht mehr das Spiel beschreiben, sondern das ist ja dann quasi mit der Meldung und dem, was in Hamburg gemacht wird, von den Kollegen, die ja die Meldung des Spiels in Hamburg machen, machen wir ja nicht vor Ort, ist das damit abgedeckt und dann fängt natürlich eigentlich schon an, in dem Fall musst du gleich kommentieren das Aus der deutschen Match in der Vorrunde. Du musst eigentlich gleich weiter denken, was passiert jetzt eigentlich, welche Umbrüche könnten jetzt geschehen, all die Sachen, die die Leute dann natürlich auch alle diskutieren, die man dann eigentlich auch nicht zwei, drei Tage später machen kann. Man kann sie dann natürlich immer noch machen und werden ja auch immer noch gemacht, aber sie müssen eigentlich dann auch am ersten Tag nach dem Spiel müssen dann zumindest schon ein paar einigermaßen kluge Gedanken dann auch schon fertig sein. Also insofern war das natürlich schon eine besondere Situation, die wenn jetzt Deutschland gegen Südkorea gewonnen hätte und ganz normal ins Achtelfinale eingezogen wäre, wäre das halt Business as Usual gewesen. Ein Text über das Spiel, eine sogenannte Personalie. Man greift sich einen Spieler raus, der für dieses Spiel in irgendeiner Form repräsentativ ist oder herausragt in sowohl positiver oder negativer Hinsicht. Und dann ein drittes Stück, wo man eben schon vorausblickt, was könnte jetzt im Achtelfinale auf diese Mannschaft zukommen. Der dritte fiel dann weg und dafür waren dann fünf andere, wie im Hydra-Haupte, wenn man das eine abgeschlagen hat, kommen gleich fünf andere dann zum Vorschein. Da musste man natürlich dann auch flexibel sein und anders reagieren. Und insofern war das dann so, das Spiel war, glaube ich, spätnachmittags um 19 Uhr, Liesigerzeit, zu Ende, dann der erste Kommentar geschrieben, bis, naja, sagen wir mal, dann geht man erst natürlich in die Pressekonferenz, Mixed Zone. Also das ist ja auch die Zeit, die dann auch noch, wenn die Leute normalerweise so im Stein nach Hause gehen, dann auch noch bei uns natürlich Hocharbeitszeit ist und auch hektisch ist. Und dann sofort im Pressezentrum den ersten Text geschrieben, so bis 21 Uhr, damit er auch am Abend noch auf die Seite kommt. Der Kollege hat dann parallel eben schon das zweite, sein zweites Stück gemacht, das zweite Stück zum Spiel. Das dann auch noch abends auf die Seite sollte, die kamen dann quasi parallel, dann auch wurden gleichzeitig dann online gestellt. Und dann konnte man eigentlich ins Hotel, wenn nicht, weil es im Turnier alles ein bisschen anders ist. Wir haben halt auch einen eigenen Kameramann dabei, erstmals, das heißt, Videoelemente haben halt natürlich auch extrem an Bedeutung gewonnen, das heißt, dass wir einfach dann auch eine Videoanalyse noch gemacht haben, das heißt, wir mussten, also es findet in so einer Art Doppelgespräch dann mit dem Kollegen, mit Markus Kremer zusammen statt und da mussten wir uns natürlich dann erstmal eine Kulisse suchen, dann sind wir dann raus aus dem Stadion, weil die Volunteers schon ganz nervös wurden, dass wir da immer noch saßen und man eigentlich schließen wollte. Also erstaunlicherweise wird hier um 23 Uhr das Pressezentrum geschlossen.
Und dann musst du dir erstmal irgendeine brennende Kulisse finden, die dann auch metaphorisch für das Ausscheiden stehen konnte.
Und das Schöne ist, dass Kazan ja wunderbar beleuchtet ist am Abend, da findet man da sowas durchaus, man konnte sagen, das Einzige, was hier glänzt und blinkt, das sind die Kremelspitzen von Kazan und sonst war nicht viel glänzendes und so weiter. Also billigste Überleitungen werden dann gestrickt, um dieses Bild zu rechtfertigen. Aber in dem Fall ging das auch noch und dann ist man damit durch und dann war es natürlich schon, ja, da ist es dann 1 Uhr nachts oder sowas und dann fängt man dann im Hotel weiter anzuschreiben. Also und dann ist es ja in Kazan so, es regt ja schon relativ weit östlich, dass es dann auch um 3 Uhr morgens schon taghell ist. Also man hat das Gefühl, man hat die Nacht ganz gut zum Arbeiten genutzt. Ja, dann am nächsten Tag früh zurückfliegen hier nach Moskau und dann, dann schon die nächste Analyse und dann war es dann auch mal gut für den Tag.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Das war natürlich ja schon, also nicht, das ist natürlich nicht das normale Arbeiten, das ist das Arbeiten, wenn Deutschland in der Vorrunde ausscheidet.
Ja, das war hektisch für alle, was ich mich ein bisschen gefragt habe, ist diese Problematik des Zeitpunktes bzw. ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Problematik ist oder ob nur ich das so sehe. Aber mir ist es aufgefallen, dass bestimmte Medien, also z.B. der Kicker, der hatte gefühlt fünf Minuten nach Schlusspfiff, es waren in Wirklichkeit wahrscheinlich eine Viertelstunde, vielleicht eine halbe Stunde, aber mehr kann es nicht gewesen sein, denn dann habe ich meine eigene Aufzeichnung begonnen und ich habe diese Push-Meteile noch bekommen. Und da kam schon der Kommentar per Push-Meteilung, in dem dann stand, jetzt muss alles hinterfragt werden, auch Löw. Und mir kam das einen Ticken zu früh, auch wenn die Dinge, die da drin standen, alle zweifelsohne richtig waren und wahrscheinlich auch hätten wir uns unterhalten direkt nach dem Schlusspfiff. Du hattest natürlich keine Zeit, ich auch nicht, aber dann hätten wir wahrscheinlich auch ähnliche Dinge gesagt. Aber ich hatte einfach das Gefühl, das ist jetzt noch zu früh, um schon so ein Meinungsartikel zu veröffentlichen, weil das wirkt dann auch so ein bisschen, als habe man auf diese Chance gewartet. Also ich finde, es gibt so einen gefühlt richtigen Zeitpunkt für Nachbetrachtungen. Wie siehst du das denn? Ihr steht ja auch in so einem Geschwindigkeitskonkurrenzkampf als Online-Medium.
Also mich erinnert das an die Nachrufe, die natürlich auch immer früher gefertigt werden, bevor diese armen Menschen dann auch wirklich das Zeitliche gesegnet haben. Die liegen ja auch alle manchmal über Jahre tatsächlich in der Schublade, bis sie dann ausgepackt werden dürfen und dann meistens gar nicht mehr so stimmen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dürfen da jetzt das richtige Wort ist, aber wir wissen, wie du es meinst.
Genau. Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass dadurch, dass das Schwedenspiel ja so eine Art vorgezogene Apokalypse schon nötig machte, ihm gedanklich, dass sich alle schon vorbereiten mussten, was tun wir denn, wenn das, was man eigentlich sonst sich nie vorstellen konnte, passiert, führt das natürlich dazu, dass man in dem durchaus, ja, also finde ich, berechtigten Bestreben, dass man sagt, wir brauchen auf jeden Fall einen Plan B, was kann denn passieren, dass manche Leute da einen gewissen Übereif an den Tag legen. Also ich finde auch, es gibt, wie, um jetzt nochmal so dieser nicht, eigentlich nicht ganz passende Analogie zum Todesfall zu benutzen, es gibt natürlich so eine gewisse Trauerzeit, also dass man dann wirklich sagt, so jetzt, na, lassen wir den erstmal, zumindest mal eine Stunde in Ruhe, bis man dann vielleicht mal anfängt zu sagen, dass es nicht so ein toller Kerl war im Leben. Und ich finde auch eine Analyse hat ja auch immer etwas, wo der Leser normalerweise denkt, da hat sich jemand Gedanken gemacht und dazu braucht er vielleicht auch ein bisschen Muße. Wenn sowas zehn Minuten oder eine Viertelstunde nach einem Spiel schon auf der Seite steht, dann hat er sich vielleicht trotzdem Gedanken gemacht, weil er das Ding ja wahrscheinlich vorher schon geschrieben hat. Aber es wirkt natürlich so wie so Batsch.
Genau.
Jetzt ist es so weit und er weckt natürlich auch den Eindruck, dass jemand dann auch einfach einen kompletten Schnellschuss hingelegt hat, auch wenn es vielleicht gar keiner ist. Aber er suggeriert natürlich irgendwie, ich habe da sofort drauf reagiert und habe sofort was Kluges aufgeschrieben und Batsch. Und das ist eigentlich dann auch zumindest schlechtes Fingerspitzengefühl, so würde ich es mal sagen. Also es ist zumindest, es ist nicht schlimm und ich finde auch, es ist jetzt nichts, wo man irgendwie den Presserat berufen müsste, aber das war natürlich eher auch überzeichnet. Aber es ist halt nicht besonders clever, würde ich mal sagen. Also in dieser Schnelligkeit als reines Tugend finde ich es sowieso lächerlich im Journalismus, dass man immer an diesen Eilmeldungen merkt, wenn man sagt, wir hatten die Eilmeldung rausgeschickt vor Bild oder vor der Süddeutschen, wenn es um zehn Sekunden geht oder so.
Genau, und dann klickst du drauf und dann steht da nur die Headline und dann Text folgt in Kürze. Und man denkt so, ja, herzlichen Dank.
Und zehn Sekunden später steht in der Süddeutschen genau dieselbe Headline oder vielleicht zwei Wörter sind anders. Und ja, das ist einfach, das ist dann wirklich sein, es ist halt so ein selbstreferenzielles Ding, dass da wirklich irgendwelche Redaktionen, also ich will nicht das Wort vom Schwanzvergleich anbringen, aber irgendwie sagen, wer ist jetzt der Schnellste, das ist einfach, ja, das ist für mich dann auch kein Kriterium, was mich in irgendeiner Weise interessiert, sondern mich interessiert natürlich dann durchaus auch die Analyse, ob der Kicker dann was Kluges gesagt hat, aber das kann er dann auch gerne eine Stunde später erst online schicken, das vergibt sowieso nichts und alle anderen Kollegen können sowieso noch nicht lesen, weil die alle selber gerade in Hochspannung sind und ich glaube auch nicht, dass ein Leser das dann schon lesen will, also genau wie du sagst, Der ist natürlich dann auch erst mal so aufgewühlt oder frustriert oder also unterschiedlichste Gefühle, die dann natürlich gerade mitspielen, wenn man so ein Spiel mit so einem ungewöhnlichen Ausgang gerade hinter sich hat und einem was dazu folgt. Und dann gleich in diesen Analyse-Status umzuschalten oder in diesen Analyse-Modus, das ist einfach auch dann tatsächlich der falsche Zeitpunkt. Dann ist ja die Emotion noch das, was eigentlich den Moment bestimmt.
Ja, das kann aber auch so eine Perspektivfrage sein. Also meinem Gefühl nach ist es schon so, dass die Debatten, die Diskussionen, die man direkt nach Schluss geführt hat, dass viele Menschen die auch gerne quasi im Monolog oder einseitig im Dialog mit Medien führen. Also sprich, es ist ein großes Interesse an jedem fitzigen Meinung und Information da, weil ja auch viele Menschen sich das selbst erklären wollen. Also ich will jetzt nicht diese dieses Ausscheiden überhöhen, aber es hat schon ein bisschen so einen Schock hinterlassen, ohne dass ich es jetzt mit irgendwelchen Tragöden vergleichen wollen würde. Aber der Mechanismus ist ein ähnlicher, dass man irgendwie die Sehnsucht hat, das jetzt eingeordnet zu bekommen, weil man sich so ganz selbst nicht ganz erklären kann. Und das glaube ich führt dann schon dazu, dass so was dann auch gelesen wird, dass so was kommentiert wird, konsumiert wird. Und das merkt man ja auch. Ihr habt ja auch eure Klickswane im Blick. Ich habe da auch mit Andreas Lehner, dem Fußballchef von Spox, drüber geredet. Der hat noch vor der Sendung zu mir gesagt, also klicktechnisch wäre der bestmögliche Ausgang. Sie kommen weiter und verlieren. Weil dann interessieren sich alle für die Artikel. Und es gibt aber noch weitere Artikel zu Deutsch. Das hat er natürlich nur im Scherz gemeint. Irgendwann wurde der Scherz dann, na gut, durch die frühe schwedische Führung war es dann irgendwann durch mit dem Sie können noch weiterkommen mit einer Niederlage. Aber man sieht schon, es ist ein hohes Interesse da. Und irgendwie ist es auch in Ordnung, das zu bedienen. Ich finde nur, manchmal driften dann Diskussionen so im Großen betrachtet in falsche Richtungen ab. Oder in Richtung, wo ich sagen würde, ist richtig falsch, ist eine Perspektivfrage, wo ich sagen würde, jetzt entfernen wir uns zu sehr vielleicht von dem Kern der Sache. Nämlich, dass das hier ein sportlicher Wettbewerb ist, dass die aus sportlichen Gründen erst mal auf dem Platz, was nicht geklappt hat, und warum das sportlich nicht geklappt hat, lässt sich auch mit anderen Dingen begründen, aber lasst uns doch vom sportlichen ausgehend diese anderen Dinge erörtern und nicht gleich einsteigen mit, die singen nicht bei der Hymne mit, die sind keine richtigen Deutschen, Erdogan und so weiter und so fort. Also manchmal, finde ich, waren die Ansatzpunkte der Diskussion, und das ging schon sehr früh los, und meinem Gefühl nach, da würde mich jetzt deine Meinung interessieren, war das bei dieser WM extremer. Natürlich haben wir so einen Vorrundenaussitz auch noch nie erlebt, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, dass diese Diskussionen, die losgelöst von sportlichen Aspekten waren, bei dieser WM fast sogar in der Mehrheit waren der Berichterstattung.
Ja, das war so. Es gab halt eigentlich nur Nebenkriegsschauplätze. Es gab keinen Hauptkriegsschauplatz. Der bricht jetzt erst aus, würde ich sagen. Das ganze Vorbereitungssermoniell lief ja auch so, wenn man es rein sportlich betrachtet, komplett störungsfrei ab. Es gab diesmal keinen spektakulären Verletztenfall, den man ja sonst immer in seine Vorberichterstattung einbauen kann.
Bis auf Neujahr?
Ja, aber das war ja eigentlich auch so ein ganz merkwürdiges Thema. Das war auch, glaube ich, ein Thema, weil man sonst keins hatte. Diese Öseel-Debatte war da noch ein bisschen, also die kochte dann ja auch so langsam hoch. Und dann am Anfang war einfach klar, es gibt nur dieses eine Neujahr-Thema, was aber auch, finde ich, vom DFB auch groß gemacht wurde, nicht nur von den Medien, weil einfach die ganze DFB-Delegation den Eindruck erweckte, wenn dieser Torwart nicht wieder fit ist, dann brauchen wir da gar nicht hinfahren, so ungefähr. Also völlig überhöht, natürlich jetzt überspitzt, aber tatsächlich hatte man so das Gefühl. Und deswegen kamen ja auch eigentlich diese Fragen auf, ja, ihr habt doch einen fantastischen Torwart Nummer zwei in der Hinterhand, traute dem gar nichts zu. Also es war ja schon so eine erste Demontage eines Spielers, die vom Verband durchaus auch mitgetragen wurde. Die Medien haben natürlich mitgemacht, haben diesen Namen, es war ja auch wirklich, was ist jetzt, wird der Fuß noch mal behandelt und so weiter. Aber es gab ja zum Beispiel auf der DFB-Website so eine Serie, Manuel Neuer, so eine tägliche Videoserie, immer nur so zwei Minuten oder drei Minuten, Manuel die Serie, wo wirklich ungefähr jede Bewegung von Manuel Neuer dann also gefilmt wurde. Und Uli Vogt, der Pressesprecher, immer nur fragte, der Fuß. Und dann sagte Manuel Neuer einen Satz, Spaß. Und dann sagte Manuel Neuer wieder einen Satz, Fitness. Also es war auch natürlich hoher Fremdschampffaktor, aber es war auch wirklich, der DFB baute sich da selbst einen Messias auf. Das, was völlig unangemessen war, weil man ja auch später gesehen hat, hakt das eigentlich überall woanders. Aber die Torwartfrage wäre jetzt wirklich nicht das gewesen, was glaube ich hier diesen Turnierverlauf sehr beeinflusst hätte.
Aber kannst du dir erklären, woher das kommt? Denn das ist ja eine neue Entwicklung, dass der DFB selbst so viel eigene Berichterstattung macht und auch Themen so offensiv setzt.
Ich glaube, es liegt auch ein bisschen daran, dass die Medienabteilung ziemlich amateurhaft besetzt ist, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Also da sitzen einfach keine Journalisten, sondern da sitzen Leute, die aus dem Verband hervorkommen sind und Oli Vogt war früher beim Fernsehen. Das muss ich natürlich dazu sagen, aber der ist einfach schon seit 25 Jahren ungefähr daraus. Der ist jetzt 65. Der ist der Pressesprecher, der zuständig ist für die Elektroniker quasi, also für Radio und Fernsehen.
Ja, wir alle haben ihn ja dann doch irgendwie kennengelernt.
Ich habe heute noch einen schwedischen Kollegen getroffen, der wirklich gesagt hat, ihr habt jetzt wirklich einen berühmtesten Pressesprecher der Welt. Also in Skandinavien kennt den jeder auf jeden Fall mittlerweile. Auswandertein sollte er vielleicht nicht mehr. Und die machen natürlich ihr eigenes Ding und ich, manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, die denken sich auch gar nicht so viel dabei. Also die bedienen natürlich dann auch diesen Personenkundengucken, was ist in der Bildzeit und gerade das große Thema. Okay, Neujahr, dann machen wir da auch mit und statt irgendwie auch mal gegen zu steuern, um einfach zu sagen, das ist die, was der Bulwana macht, das ist lächerlich. Wir haben den Standort vom FC Barcelona und wenn Manuel Neuer wirklich nicht fit wird, dann haben wir den. Das wurde halt überhaupt auch nicht kommuniziert. Das wurde dann immer gesagt, ja, der hat eine tolle Saison gemacht, da standen Bierhoff und Löw und wir haben natürlich auch Vertrauen in ihn, aber das war immer so im Nebensatz nachdem vorher also die große Hymne auf Manuel Neuer gesungen wurde. Natürlich haben die beim DFB eben auch die Turniere der Vergangenheit im Kopf, haben auch die Fehler von der Stegener Nationalmannschaft auch natürlich im Kopf, obwohl die schon lange her sind mittlerweile und wissen natürlich, was so Neuer auch ausmacht und das dann natürlich auch Erfrucht gebieten kann.
Klar, aber wenn Neuer jetzt nicht fit geworden wäre, dann wäre Marc-Andre Ter Stegen ein Stück weit demontiert in dieses Turnier gegangen, ohne dafür irgendetwas zu können. Und das ist doch eigentlich auch kein respektvoller Umgang mit dem eigenen Spieler.
Ja, und es ist natürlich auch einfach, es schadet dem eigenen Team letztlich. Es ist also komplett auch kontraproduktiv. Also man hätte das anders anfangen müssen und hätte einfach sagen müssen, wir haben ein Interessent-Ding, aber das ist unser Mannschaftskapitän und wir versuchen alles. Wenn es nicht klappt, klappt es nicht und wenn es klappt, klappt es. Also man hätte das auch mit so einer Gelassenheit kommunizieren können, die ich da gar nicht gespürt habe. Und das wurde dann ja quasi da nahtlos abgelöst durch diese Ösel-Thematik. Also insofern hast du natürlich Recht, war da schon immer Unruhe. Andererseits, wenn ich so an das Trainingslager 2014 zurückdenke, war die Unruhe viel größer. Da gab es vorher das Pokalfinale, wo sich Lahm, Neuer und Schweinsteiger, glaube ich, verletzt hatten. Also nicht ganz unwichtige Spieler, die in dem ganzen Trainingslager, glaube ich, auch keinen Ball in der Hand hatten. Also wo man wirklich sagen musste, da steht schon das ganze Projekt mit auf dem Spiel. Dann gab es diesen Mercedes-Unfall bei dieser Werbetour, wo ein Rentner in Südtirol dann von Pascal Wehrlein fast halbtot gefahren worden ist.
Also Benedikt Hürde saß auf dem Ballchaber.
Ja, richtig. Und Mustafi, glaube ich, auch noch. Oder Drax, das waren die beiden Schalker. Dazu Sauwetter, die konnten nie richtig trainieren, weil es dauernd geregnet hat. Also konnten zwar trainieren, aber eben nicht so. Jo Löw, der ja bekanntlich Sonnenanbeter ist, was ja bei dieser WM auch eine Rolle spielte. Also da war die Unruhe viel größer. Und eigentlich alle Journalisten reisten nach Hause und waren sich sicher, irgendwie das geht alles schief. Und die Mannschaft selbst hat sich halb tot gelacht letztlich. Also alles irgendwie, Sachen, das kriegen wir schon alles hin. Und ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch so ein Unterschied gewesen von vier Jahren. Dass das 2014 richtig war von der Mannschaft. Und wenn sie 2018 das wirklich wieder gedacht haben sollte, ha ha ha, wir kriegen das alles hin und das habe ich das Gefühl, dass sie das gedacht haben, weil auch die Stimmen nach dem Scheitern so ein bisschen in diese Richtung gingen, dann war es leider die falsche Wiederholung, die richtige Wiederholung am falschen Ort oder die falsche Wiederholung am richtigen Ort. Auf jeden Fall war es falsch.
Das hat auf jeden Fall nicht gepasst. Und wie bewertest du, wie sich der DFB gegenüber Journalisten verhalten hat? Also es wurde ja immer mal wieder am Rande, auch im Rasenfunk thematisiert, die Zugänge werden immer mehr abgeschnitten. Die 15 Minuten vom Training, die man beobachten kann, werden nur noch zum warmen Laufen verwendet. Jetzt in Watutinki ist es vorgekommen, dass einzelne Journalisten ihre Fragen gar nicht mehr loswerden konnten an bestimmte Spiele. Dafür andere Journalisten immer aufgerufen werden. Hat sich da etwas verändert oder nehmen wir das ein bisschen deutlicher jetzt wahr, weil eben auch man inzwischen viel, viel einfacher vor Ort mit dabei sein kann, in Anführungszeichen von Deutschland aus?
Ich glaube tatsächlich, es ist das Erste, weil es gibt halt noch so ein paar andere kleine Anzeichen, die zeigen, dass sich was verändert hat. Zum Beispiel, dass man jetzt bei den ersten beiden Spielen die Aufstellung vorher wieder durchgesickert ist. Das hatte man auch jahrelang nicht. Das gab es einmal 2012 bei der EM, wo Löw auch sehr verärgert reagiert hat. Und dann war das Thema erledigt. Es ist 2014 nie vollkommen, 2016 nie vollkommen. Jetzt ist es halt zweimal wieder vorgekommen.
Aber haben die denn gestimmt, die Aufstellung? Waren die nicht beide fehlerhaft dadurch?
Es waren, glaube ich, von den vier Wechseln waren drei richtig und einer war nicht richtig. Und komischerweise, als es darum ging, die vier Spieler in Südtirol auszurelegieren, die vom vorläufigen Endgürteln in Katergarten waren, war es genauso. Da waren drei Namen richtig und einer war falsch. Es kann natürlich sein, dass da die Bildzeitung, dass der DFB mit der Bildzeitung ein gewisses Spiel spielt. Wir sagen euch was, aber wir sagen euch nicht die ganze Wahrheit. Und ihr müsst rausfinden, wer der Falsche ist. So ein Hütchenspiel, journalistisches Hütchenspiel. Aber jedenfalls passiert das überhaupt erst wieder mal.
Wir hatten das 2016 auch, aber da hat es halt nicht gestimmt. Das weiß ich noch.
Genau.
Da gab es zwei Mal bei den drei Vorrundenspielen eine exklusive Ausstellung und die war beides mal falsch. Und einmal hieß es dann auch O. Da hat sich dann auch einer der Bildreporter bei Twitter geäußert, meinte, ja, also sonst war diese Quelle immer sehr zuversichtlich.
Diesmal war es ja auch so in Sochi zum Beispiel, dass die Bild die Nationalmannschaft unter einem Dach residierte. Es soll angeblich auch Zufall gewesen sein, weil die Bild das Hotel vorher schon gebucht hatte für ihre Jungs und dann die Nationalmannschaft da reingezogen ist. Aber dass es dann ausgerechnet die Bild ist, die mit der Nationalmannschaft zufällig unter einem Dach wohnt, ist natürlich dann auch wieder so ein Zufall, wo man nicht mehr so unbedingt an Zufall glaubt. Davon abgesehen, was du natürlich eigentlich gefragt hast, es wird schon von Turnier zu Turnier komplizierter mit den Zugängen. Also zum Beispiel hat es jetzt bei diesem Turnier, was natürlich auch recht kurz war, während des Turniers fast kein einziges Einzelinterview mehr gegeben, sondern in Südtirol war das noch möglich, begrenzt auch. Aber sonst war es auch so, dass waren im Turnier zumindest noch einige mehr in die Welt öfter oder manchmal auch die Zeit, kriegten dann noch was. Und diesmal war gar nichts. Also die haben sich noch mehr abgeschottet, als sie es eh schon tun. Und natürlich ist das auch so, jetzt aus Sicht der Nationalwirtschaft, jetzt keine so besonders gute Entwicklung, weil Journalisten halt auch Menschen sind und negative Gefühle in sich aufsteigen, spüren.
Ja, klar.
Und dann auch entsprechend vielleicht noch nicht mal bewusst, aber unbewusst an das Bericht erstatten, als wenn sie offenere Türen hätten. Und es gibt immer bei jedem Turnier so einen Moment wo der Unmut relativ groß ist. Unter den Journalisten, über die Medienabteilung, über die Pressearbeit des DFB. Diesmal war es aber schon so, dass das schon im Vorbereitungscamp war. Also schon im Südtirol. Vielleicht in der Ahnung, dass man ja nicht so lange in Russland bleiben würde, hat man das in Unmut schon vorgezogen.
Und wird das thematisiert? Also man spricht ja dann auch viel außerhalb der Pressekonferenz. Und da könnte man ja auch mal sagen, also Entschuldigung, aber so wie ihr es hier gerade macht, wie sollen wir so arbeiten? Ihr könnt euch nicht auf der einen Seite beschweren, dass wir die immer gleichen Themen...
Die haben natürlich immer ihre Erklärungen. Die sagen immer, das Sportliche geht halt vor. Und ihr wisst doch, warum wir hier sind, nicht um Medienarbeit zu machen und so weiter und fort. Die Jungs von der Medien-Teilung tun mir ja auch ein bisschen leid, ehrlich gesagt. Weil die Mannschaft ist halt auch... Also Löw zum Beispiel ist Medienarbeit sowas von egal. Das spielt für den halt überhaupt keine Rolle. Das ist dem komplett wurscht. So ein kleines Beispiel, als er diese vier Namen verkündet hat, da waren ja keine Rückfragen zugelassen. Bei dieser Pressekonferenz, als er also ein E und so weiter nicht mitgenommen hat. Und er geht dann raus, und dann kommt ein neuer und wird angesprochen, ich glaube von Jens Mende von der DPA. Und Löw halt da ganz fast arg los erzählt ihm dann alles. Da stehen auch drei, vier andere Kollegen vom Kicker und von der Bild oder so, die dann immer so reflexartig mit rauslaufen, wenn der Bundestrainer rausgeht. Und die hatten das dann natürlich. Und dann hieß es dann in der Agentur, ja, Löw begründete dann anschließend seine Auswahl im kleinen Kreis. Das ist natürlich medienarbeitsmäßig eine Vollkatastrophe. Alle anderen Journalisten, die brav in der Neuer PK sitzen geblieben sind, fühlen sich natürlich komplett vereimert. Und dann, da ist natürlich eine Medienabteilung auch gefordert, dann dem Bundestrainer zu sagen, ey, entweder sagst du allen was oder sagst keinem was. Und wenn man dann die Medienleute darauf anspricht, dann sagen die halt, naja, das ist aber auch die Undiszipliniertheit der Kollegen, die hinter dem Herr laufen, hinter dem Löw. Da muss man die halt mehr disziplinieren. Die machen natürlich nur ihren Job, das ist doch klar. Und da sieht man halt auch, dass dieses Binnenverhältnis zwischen Medienabteilung und der eigentlichen Spitze beim DFB oder den Spielern halt auch nicht so ist, dass die Kopf haben, dass das wichtig ist, mit Journalisten was zu machen. Für die ist das halt einfach, die Journalisten sind halt da, die braucht man eigentlich überhaupt nicht. Man braucht vielleicht ein paar Kollegen, wenn man mal was transportieren will, aber die haben ja alle ihre eigenen Social Media Accounts. Wenn sie was loswerden wollen, können sie es da machen. Journalisten sind eigentlich bei Werk so. Und wenn die Medienabteilung nicht stark genug ist, dem dann entgegenzuwirken und sagen, ey, ihr müsst jetzt aber, lieber Ilkay Gündogan, lieber Mesut Öze, ihr müsst jetzt einfach vor die Presse gehen, auch wenn es richtig unangenehm für euch wird, aber dann habt ihr es wenigstens hinter euch. Wenn die nicht die Kraft und den Einfluss haben, so was zu sagen, dann geht so was natürlich schief. Und das ist natürlich komplett in die Rose gegangen.
Ja, vor allem, ich finde es insofern interessant. Normalerweise könnte man ja sagen, das ist jetzt eine Debatte, die für Journalisten sehr wichtig ist und für die Öffentlichkeit zum Teil schon auch, aber erste Aufgabe des DFB-Trosses ist es ja tatsächlich, erst mal dieses Turnier zu spielen. Aber ich finde, es wird dahingehend dann schon ein wichtiges Thema, wenn man dann wiederum aus der Mannschaft hört, dass die Art der Berichterstattung thematisiert wird. Von Toni Kroos, der das erwähnt hat, und auch bei anderen hat man es auch immer wieder so im Subtext rausgehört, eine Unzufriedenheit auch über die Art und Weise, wie über die Nationalmannschaft berichtet werden würde. Wo man dann auch nicht so ganz genau weiß, wen konkret hat man damit gemeint. Oder meinten sie vielleicht sogar auch, was unter ihren Social-Media-Postings so an Kommentaren reinkam. Es soll ja doch noch Spieler geben, die da reingucken, und dann kriegen die recht schnell ein Stimmungsbild mit. Das kann ich jedem sagen, der mit Social Media nicht so viel am Hut hat. Das geht innerhalb von Sekunden, dass man weiß, wie die Leute gerade so drauf sind. Aber ich finde, ab diesem Moment wird es dann schon ein Thema, wo man dann auch vielleicht mal nicht Kontra geben muss, aber das mal einordnen muss. Ich habe mir das zum Beispiel gedacht, als Thomas Müller und Marco Reus am Donnerstag nach dem Schwedenspiel auf der Pressekonferenz saßen und das Schwedenspiel war am Sonntag. Und dann gab es noch mal eine Frage eines Kollegen, der nach dem Schwedenspiel gefragt hat. Und die Antwort von Thomas Müller war, ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, warum ich jetzt noch zum Schwedenspiel nicht äußern muss. Zum Mexikospiel, Entschuldigung. Und eigentlich hätte man dann sagen müssen, ich meine, wahrscheinlich war das Mikro schon weg, aber eigentlich hätte der Journalist nochmal das Mikro nehmen müssen und hätte sagen müssen, ne Entschuldigung, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz was zu sagen. Direkt danach konnten wir, also direkt danach Feed-Interview, da wart ihr alle voller Adrenalin, es wäre ungerecht, alles da auf die Goldwaage zu legen. Am nächsten Tag hatten wir keinen Zugang, dann gab es keine Pressekonferenz, dann saß hier mal eine Neue, hat 15 Mal dasselbe gesagt, welche Frage wir ihm gestellt haben. Und jetzt sitzen sie halt hier und deswegen muss ich die Frage jetzt stellen.
Vor allen Dingen, wo er ja durchaus vorher auch noch einiges selbst zum Schwedenspiel gesagt hat, um deutlich zu machen, wie selbstkritisch diese Niederlage, also zum Mexikospiel, wie selbstkritisch sie diese Niederlage aufgenommen haben. Thomas Müller ist natürlich ein Sonderfall, der reagiert halt gerne mal bei Pressekonferenzen ein bisschen, ja wie soll man das sagen, angezickt ist so ein blödes Wort, aber es ist schon so, da ergibt ganz gerne Journalisten einen mit. Das gehört zu seiner Natur dazu. Das ist auch immer sehr abhängig bei ihm, so ein recht schmales Band zwischen dieser Launigkeit, die er natürlich hat und die ihm manchmal gut ist und manchmal nicht so gelungen ist, und dem so ein bisschen aggressiven, offensiv aggressiven würde ich mal sagen, was er bei ihm dann auch manchmal so mitspielt. Er ist ja wirklich schon auch ein cleverer, intelligenter Bursche und der merkt natürlich auch gerade, wenn es halt nicht so läuft, dass es eben nicht bei ihm läuft. Und das aber zuzugeben, fällt ihm ein bisschen schwer. Und dann, das war bei der EM auch schon so, dann flüchtet er sich so ein bisschen in so eine etwas, ja, überlegene Attitüde, die ihm dann, glaube ich, auch nicht so richtig gut tut. Aber das ist eben so Müller-spezifisch. Und ansonsten ist es natürlich so, klar, spricht man das schon an. Also aber gerne eben natürlich dann immer den Medien-Abteilungsleuten. Die sind dann auch immer eher so gepolt, dass sie dann die Interessen der Mannschaft eher vertreten. Also da hat sich einfach was getan seit Harald Stenger, nicht mehr der Sprecher und der Medienrektor ist. Der hat schon auch vor allem immer das Interesse der Journalisten gesehen und das versucht, den Spielern klar zu machen. Und jetzt ist es ja umgekehrt. Die versuchen uns die Interessen der Spieler zu pimsen. Die Interessen der Spieler sind uns aber auch eigentlich völlig klar. Die wollen natürlich in Ruhe gelassen werden und die wollen sich auf dieses Spiel konzentrieren. Das brauche ich nicht jeden Tag erklärt bekommen. Und jeder hat da auch Verständnis für, dass die Zeiten, dass da irgendwelche Fotografen im Baum hängen und dann irgendwelche Spieler beim Training fotografieren wollen. Wer macht das denn schon noch? Das ist in Ausnahmefällen mal die Bild, aber sonst macht das auch keiner mehr. Sondern es wird ja auch respektiert, dass sie wirklich konzentriert arbeiten müssen, dass die Ruhe abwesend, dass die Trainings mal geschlossen sind. Es gibt ja genug Dinge, aber das hat halt komplett überhand genommen. Und das betrifft ja nicht nur den Journalisten.
Man kann immer diese Rege nicht respektieren, legt man sich dann immer wieder in ein Bett. Also Toni Kroos kanzelt die Berichterstattung ab und schreibt danach exklusiv in der Bild über die WM, wo ich mir auch denke, man weiß schon, wie das dann immer alles so grob zustande kommt. Aber warum hat da niemand beim DFB die Rundumsicht und sagt, Moment mal, das ist jetzt schwierig?
Schlau ist das nicht, das kann man einfach nur sagen. Da habe ich dann wirklich auch so ein gewisses Gefühl, dass es natürlich die Beißhemmung von der Bild schon groß ist. Weil die Bild hatte diese unsägliche Geschichte mit dem Selfie von Julian Brandt nach dem Mexikospiel, wo wirklich alle nur den Kopf geschüttelt haben. Also egal, ob das Journalisten waren oder Spieler oder wie auch immer. Oder auch jeder, der noch seine 5 Sinne einigermaßen beisammen hat. Es ist doch wohl klar, dass der ein Foto mit dem macht, mit dem Kind. Aber dann wird einfach nicht Ross und Reiter genannt. Dann wird so in einer nebulösen Art davon gesprochen, dass die Presse kritisch sei. Wie Kimmich gesagt hat, das Land steht hinter uns, die Presse ist kritisch. Das ist auch so ein Satz, den man, glaube ich, aufs T-Shirt sich mal drucken lassen könnte. Und ja, dann sollen sie einfach sagen, ey, ihr Bildleute, das da mit Julian Brandt, das war einfach eine Sauerei. Und das sage ich jetzt mal ins Mikrofon, die Kamera für ganz Deutschland. So geht das nicht. Aber ja, das passiert einfach nicht. Und dann werden alle in Mithaftung genommen. Und natürlich reagieren dann gerade die seriösen Journalisten auch ein bisschen angepisst und beleidigt, weil sie sagen, ey, wir üben Kritik. Aber natürlich üben wir Kritik, weil es Anlass zur Kritik hat. Aber wir sind nicht diejenigen, die sagen peinlich Selfie.
Genau. Und das ist ja dann auch irgendwie schwierig. Also es gab dann genügend Kommentare, die dann wiederum das Toni-Kroos-Zitat, mit dem viele hätten sich gewünscht, dass wir ausscheiden nach dem Schwedenschwi, eingeordnet haben. Und da war dann ganz oft der Subtext, naja uns, also mich, der hier jetzt gerade schreibt, mich kannst du ja eigentlich nicht gemeint haben. Und das ist natürlich auch eine Argumentationslinie, die man führen kann, die aber halt auch manchmal auf dünnem Ei steht, weil man sich selbst ja letztlich auch auf so ein eigenes Podest stellt. Und die Schwierigkeit, die ich damit auch habe, ist letztlich weiß keiner, wie hat es Toni-Kroos eigentlich gemeint. Und es gab aber auch keine Möglichkeit, ihn nochmal zu fragen. Toni, du hast es damals direkt nach dem Spiel gesagt. War das einfach noch, weil du voller Adrenalin warst? Oder erklärst uns bitte nochmal, wie kommst du zu der Aussage? Und es gab ja keine Möglichkeit, das einordnen zu lassen. Und deswegen muss man da so rummeandern. Und das tut ja niemandem gut. Ich fand das auch in die Verteidigungshaltung der Medien teilweise ein bisschen zu. Also teilweise hatte man den Eindruck auch, es gäbe da draußen nur investigativ sachliche Engel.
Gibt das ja auch.
Ja, aber nicht ausschließlich.
Redest doch gerade mit an.
Ja, natürlich, das ja sowieso.
Aber es liegt natürlich ganz klar daran, dass man mit Toni-Kroos dann nur einmal in diesen 5 Minuten reden kann. Und dann ist er vielleicht für 3 Wochen wieder weg. Und dann wird er irgendwann vom Halbfinale, so war Gott will, wenn es eins gäbe, wird er dann nochmal für die Presse gesetzt. Und dann fragt ja keiner mehr 3 Wochen später, wie war denn eigentlich dieses Zitat damals gemeint, an das ich mich so undunkel noch dran erinnern kann. Und natürlich ist das dann komplett, ich finde das auch ungut, wenn man sich dann auf so einen Sockel setzt und sagt, ach, das sind ja die bösen Boulevard-Leute. Vor allem bei Toni-Kroos weiß man ja auch nie, der kann ja auch genauso die SZ oder den Spiegel oder wem auch immer gemeint haben. Aber das wäre alles ganz einfach aus der Welt zu schaffen, wenn der gute Mann dann einfach sagen würde, das war nicht in Ordnung. Und das ist eigentlich auch kein großes Kunstwerk, so was zu machen. Und es sind eben so viele Sachen, die so einfach wären. Also auch diese ganze Ölse-Gündogan-Geschichte. Man hätte das so anders alles regeln können. Und das hat natürlich dann auch so wie so ein Mehl-Tau über dieser Mannschaft gehangen. Also Tegedira hat heute ja auch nochmal gesagt, das hat uns durchaus geschadet. Es hat halt vor allem diesen beiden Spielern geschadet, weil die komplett ohne Form und völlig verunsichert in dieses Turnier gegangen ist. Also weil hätte die wahrscheinlich sogar noch größeren Gefallen getan. Man hätte sie gar nicht nominiert danach. Hätte gesagt, ihr habt einen Fehler gemacht, wir müssen jetzt so konsequent sein. Und nach der WM seid ihr wieder herzlich willkommen. Das wäre halt auch eine Möglichkeit gewesen. Es war eine ganz harte. Aber so haben die beiden ja eigentlich niemanden genützt. Vor allem Gündo an nicht. Also Gündo an, der eigentlich Löws Traum-Sechser ist neben groß. War ja wirklich ein Trauerspiel, ihn dann spielen zu sehen, wie er sich nichts traute, wie er jeden Ball zwei Meter schnell wieder abgab. Bloß nicht, um in die Gefahr zu geraten, wieder einen Fehler zu machen. So einen Spieler kannst du wirklich bei der WM dann überhaupt nicht gebrauchen. Und das haben sie sich komplett selbst zuzuschreiben. Bei den Spieler, aber vor allem eben der Verband.
Genau. Und dann ist der Verband nicht dafür bekannt, dass sie sich danach auch mal hinstellen und sagen, da haben wir Fehler gemacht, das machen wir deutlich anders. Sondern da kommen dann eben auch so Themen, die eigentlich primär gar nichts damit zu tun haben. Aber das ganze Vermarktungsprämborium, das Ganze nach außen sich als Brand etablieren und mit Sponsornterminen und allem, das hat eigentlich alles mit der Sache nichts zu tun. Aber ich glaube, auf dieser Ebene kommt das dann häufig mit rein, dass man sagt, das ist einfach stellvertretend für den DFB aktuell. Jetzt, wie lange bist du denn schon nah am DFB dran? Und wie würdest du jetzt sagen, ist das jetzt ein Tiefpunkt der Beziehung zwischen Journalisten und dem DFB seit den Boulevardgeschichten, die es rund um die 94er WM, die 90er WM war da auch ganz gut, gab? Wie würdest du das einordnen in einer größeren Perspektive?
Also, das habe ich natürlich alles auch nur als Fernsehzuschauer mitbekommen damals. Auch das berühmte Interview mit Harry Valerian und Paul Breit namens Swimpool 1982, wo die sich so gefetzt haben, dass man mal dachte, gleich fällt einer ins Wasser. Ich mache das jetzt seit 2010 mit der Nationalmannschaft und stelle schon fest, dass das Verhältnis schwieriger geworden ist. Und ich will nicht sagen Tiefpunkt, das kann ja auch immer noch schlechter werden. Der DFB bemüht sich natürlich auch, um so was mit Medientagen durchaus auch Möglichkeiten zu schaffen, die ich als wirklich okay empfinde. Also, dass man dann mit den Spielern, wenn es nur eine Viertelstunde ist, reden kann, ohne dass es autorisiert werden muss zum Beispiel. Also, die sind dann wirklich dafür verantwortlich, was sie sagen. Da wird dann nichts mehr geglättet. Auch bei diesen Pool-Interviews, die es ja sonst bei Turnieren auch manchmal gab, dass dann zehn Journalisten mit einem Spieler sich nochmal 20 Minuten hinsetzen konnten. Auch das wurde nicht autorisiert, das ist schon in Ordnung. Also, es ist nicht alles schlecht, um mal einen beliebten Satz zu zitieren. Aber man schleppt von Turnier zu Turnier immer so ein Stück Missmut mehr mit sich herum. Und jeder kleine Anlass oder auch größere Anlass führt dann dazu, dass man den Missmut aus den Vorturnieren auch noch mit abrufen kann und denkt, oh ja, es geht schon wieder los, die Presseabteilung, und jetzt werden wir wieder gegängelt. Oder das oft so ist, wenn man mit den Pressesprechern kommunizieren will, dass die nicht ins Telefon gehen oder solche Sachen. Was alles passieren kann, aber man hakt es dann immer gleich schon wieder ab unter, ja ja, so ist sie halt, die Medienabteilung beim DFB. Also es sind einfach keine guten Voraussetzungen geschaffen. Es wäre einfach Zeit für vertrauensbildende Maßnahmen.
Eine Partei zwischen DFB und Journalisten.
Möglicherweise. Also dass es zumindest auch mal zwischen den Turnieren einfach auch mehr Kontakte gibt zum Beispiel. Oder dass die sich vielleicht auch mal erklären und vielleicht auch ein paar Situationen aus dem Turnier dann im Nachhinein nochmal erläutern, warum sie so gehandelt haben. Das würde schon dazu beitragen. Es ist ohnehin keine Zusammenarbeit in dem Sinne, wo man immer sagt, liebe Kollegen, weil man dann immer sagt, das ist ja nicht so eigentlich. Und dann bedanken wir uns für die gute Zusammenarbeit. Das Wort Zusammenarbeit hat ja dann schon so ein Geschmäckle. Aber es ist ja auch kein Gegeneinander eigentlich im Sinne. Es ist ja nicht so, dass per se die DFB-Mediaabteilung die Journalisten als Gegner im Turnier mit der Lanze aufeinander losreiten. Sondern man muss halt miteinander auskommen. Und man muss halt die Ansprüche der einen Seite und der anderen Seite miteinander abgleichen. Und das passiert halt nicht im ausreichenden Maße. Also nur so ein Mini-Beispiel, dann ist dieser Medientag endlich angesagt, am letzten Tag dieser Vorbereitung. Bitte pünktlich erscheinen, 12.30 Uhr, dann brütend heiß, in Südtirol, da sitzen die Journalisten in diesem Hotelgarten gesetzt. Und erst mal zweieinhalb Stunden passiert nichts. Also weil die Spieler erst Mittag essen müssen. Das weiß man entweder doch vorher oder man bestellt die Journalisten einfach um 14 Uhr. Dann fühlt sich dann einfach wie das fünfte Rad am Wagen. Man fühlt sich dann einfach nicht ernst genommen. Und das ist einfach unprofessionell, würde ich sagen. Also man lässt den Journalisten, man kann ja mal einen Journalisten zweieinhalb Stunden warten lassen, aber nicht 150 Journalisten, die alle in der Hitze sitzen. Und alle schon auf ihrer Abreise.
Na gut, das ist wenigstens gleichberechtigte Gängelung. Also insofern dann ja schon wieder eigentlich vorbildhaft.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, es hat auf Augenhöhe den Unmut dann gegeben. Das stimmt.
Wahnsinn.
Aber es ist einfach, es ist einfach, ja, unklug.
Und unprofessionell. Ich glaube, das steht schon so ein bisschen drunter. Letzte Frage, Peter, auch wenn ich tatsächlich, wir haben schon vorher darüber gesprochen, wir könnten Stunden über dieses Thema sprechen. Bei wie viel Prozent würdest du denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit einordnen, dass es da jetzt eine Verbesserung gibt in den nächsten Monaten in der Medienarbeit des DFB oder geht das jetzt immer so weiter?
Die Frage, also wie viel sich beim DFB allgemein verändert, die wird man wahrscheinlich als Ende nächster Woche richtig beantworten können. Wenn es eben darum geht, macht Löw weiter oder macht er nicht weiter? Und ich glaube, wenn Löw nicht weiter macht, wird es beim DFB viel mehr verändern, als nur, dass der Bundestrainer anders heißen wird. Sondern da geht es wirklich darum, dass ganze Stäbe sich wahrscheinlich neu orientieren müssen, nach so einem Vorrundenausjahr ohnehin. Man überlegen muss, ob man diesen Wasserkopf-DFB-Stuff mit fast 65 Leuten bei jedem Turnier und in der Vorbereitung mit 150 Leuten, wie viele SUVs da rumstehen. Das wird ja auch jedem Umweltschützer dann auch wirklich die Haare zu Berge steigen lassen. Also da wird sich dann wahrscheinlich viel mehr tun. Und das kann natürlich auch für eine Medienabteilung Veränderungen bedeuten. Personellerart und auch im Umgang. Abgesehen davon, dass wir werden, glaube ich, wenn viele von den älteren Spielern abtreten, jüngere Spieler, die vielleicht dann noch ein bisschen lästigeres Verhältnis zur Presse haben, möglicherweise. Und nicht so immer auf der Hut sind.
Klingt ein bisschen wie ein frommer Wunsch, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, es ist natürlich ein frommer Wunsch. Ich habe mir eben schon so warmige Hilfe irgendwo mal untergebracht. Und da ist natürlich fromm, klar. Also man könnte natürlich auch sagen, beim DFB ändert sich nie was. Aber so pessimistisch bin ich dann vielleicht doch nicht. Um dann natürlich in einem Jahr zu sagen, beim DFB hat sich nichts geändert.
Das ist ja eh klar. Und ich werde dir dafür sorgen, dass du es hier im Rasenfunkt tust, lieber Peter. Peter, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Edpeter-Ahrens bei Twitter vom Spiegel. Ich kann das Folgen sehr, sehr, sehr empfehlen. Und vielen Dank, Peter, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, aus deinem russischen Enklave heraus hier mit mir zu sprechen.
Sehr gerne.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke fürs Zuhören. Die Achtelfinalpartien, die heute stattfinden, haben wir im gestrigen Kurzpass schon besprochen, wem das jetzt gefehlt hat. Und dann hören wir uns morgen wieder. Die täglichen WM-Kurzpässe gehen weiter, denn hier gibt es natürlich immer was über die WM zu berichten. Ich mache jetzt keinen Urlaub. Wir hören uns morgen wieder. Bis dahin, machts gut, ciao.